I'm Deb's son and I'm Hanks mom we've
said that so many times we've made a
peace about it
it's called sometimes I see myself in
you and it speaks to the symbiotic
relationship that we've developed over
the years through our life and work and
it really it's because everywhere we go
together apart we carry these monikers
I've been following in my mother's
footsteps since before I was even born
and haven't figured out how to stop and
as I get older it does get harder no
seriously it gets harder
my mother's taught me many things though
most of all that love overrules she's
taught me that love is an action not a
feeling love is a way of being it's a
way of doing it's a way of listening and
it's a way of seeing and and also the
idea about love photographers they're
looking for love when they make
photographs they're looking and looking
and finding love growing up in North
Philadelphia I was surrounded by people
in my family and friends who made
photographs and use the family camera as
a way of telling a story about life
about life of joy about what it meant to
become a family in North Philadelphia so
I spent most of my life searching for
pictures that reflect on ideas about
black love black joy and about family
life so it's really important to think
about the action of love overrules as a
verb sometimes I wonder if the love of
looking is genetic because like my
mother I've loved photographs since
before I can even remember I think
sometimes that after my mother and her
mother that photography and photographs
were my first love no offense to my
father but that's what you get for
calling me a ham
wherever you go I remember whenever I go
to my grandmother's house you would hide
all the photo albums because she was
afraid of me asking well who's that in
that picture and who are they to you and
who are they to me and how old were you
when that picture was taken how old was
I when that picture was taken and why
were they in black and white was the
world in black and white before I was
born
Wow that's interesting just to think
about the world in black and white I
grew up in a beauty shop in North
Philadelphia my mom's beauty shop
looking at evany magazine found images
that told stories that were often not in
the family album not in the daily news
but in the family album I wanted the
family album to be energetic for me a
way of telling stories one day I happen
upon a book in the Philadelphia public
library called the sweet flypaper of
life by roy decarava and Langston Hughes
I think what attracted me as a
seven-year-old the title flypaper and
sweet but to think about that as a 7
year old I looked at the beautiful
images that roy decarava made and then
looked at ways that I could tell a story
about life and looking for me is the act
that basically changed my life my friend
Chris Johnson told me that every
photographer every artist is essentially
trying to answer one question and I
think your question might have been why
doesn't the rest of the world see how
beautiful we are
and what can I do to help them see that
our community the way I do well study in
art school it's probably true I had a
male professor who told me that I was
taking up a good man's space he tried to
stifle my dream of becoming a
photographer he attempted to shame me in
a class full of male photographers he
was he told me I was out of place and
now to order as a woman and he went on
to say that all you could and would do
was to have a baby when it when a good
man could have had your seat in this
class I was shocked into silence in
today experience but I had my camera and
I was determined to prove to him that I
was worthy for a seat in that class but
in retrospect I asked myself why did I
need to prove it to him you know I had
my camera and I knew I needed to prove
to myself that I would make a difference
in photography I love photography and no
one was going to stop me from making
images
but that's when I came in yeah that year
I graduated I got pregnant yep he was
right and I had you and I took off that
sexist language that he used against me
and picked up my camera and made
photographs daily and made photographs
of my pregnant belly but as I prepared
for graduate school but I thought about
also that black photographers were
missing from the history books of
photography and I was looking for ways
to tell a story and I ran across Gordon
Parks his book a choice of weapons which
was his autobiography I began
photographing and making images and I
tucked away those that contact sheet
that I made of my pregnant belly and
then you inspired me to create a new
piece a piece that said a woman taking a
plate a place from a good man
you took the space from a good man and
then I used that language and reversed
it and said I made a space for a good
man you like mother like son I up in a
house full of photographs they were
everywhere and my mother would turn the
kitchen into a dark room and there
weren't just pictures that she took in
pictures of family members but there
were pictures on the wall of and by
people that we didn't know men and women
that we didn't know thanks MA I have my
own timing puppet strings I grew up in a
house full of photographs but they were
just pictures of men and women that we
knew but pictures of people that I
didn't know pretty much I was pretty
clear from what I learned in school that
the rest of the world didn't either
and it took me a long time to figure out
what she was up to but after a while I
figured out when I was nine years old
she published this book black
photographers 1840 to 1940 a
bio-bibliography and it was astounding
to me to consider that in 1840
Americans were making photographs what
does it mean for us to think that at a
time that was two three decades before
the end of slavery that people were
learning how to read they had to learn
how to do math they had to be on the
cutting edge of science and technology
to do math physics and chemistry just to
make a single photograph and what
compelled them to do that if not love
well that book led her to her next book
black photographers 1942 1988 and that
book led to another book and another
book and another book and another book
and another book and another book and
another book and another book another
book said another book another book and
another book another book another book
and over throughout my life she's edited
and published dozens of books and
curated numerous exhibitions on every
continent not all about black
photographers but all inspired by the
curiosity of a little black girl from
North till Adelphia what I found is that
black photographers had stories to tell
and and we needed to listen and then I
found that I discovered black a black
photographers like Augustus Washington
who made this beautiful Dario types of
the McGill family in the early 1840s and
50s their stories tended to be different
black photographers and they had a
different narrative about black life
during slavery but was also about family
life beauty and telling stories about
community and didn't know what I had to
link the stories but I knew that
teachers needed to know this story so I
think I was my mother's first student
unwillingly
and unwittingly puppies shrinks I
decided to pick up a camera and thought
that I should make my own pictures about
the then and now and then now and then I
thought about how I could use
photography to talk about how what's
going on outside of the frame of the
camera can affect what we see inside the
truth is always in the hands of the
actually image maker and it's up to us
to really consider what's being cut out
I thought I could use her research as a
jumping-off point of things I was seeing
in society
and I wanted to start to think about how
I could use historical images to talk
about the past being present and think
about ways that we can speak to the
perennial struggle for human rights and
equal rights through my appropriation of
photographs in the form of sculpture
video installation and paintings but
through it all one piece you know has
affected me the most it continues to
nourish me it's based off of this
photograph by artist withers who took
this picture in 1968 the myth at the
Memphis sanitation workers march of men
and women standing collectively to
affirm their humanity they were holding
signs that said I am a man and I found
that astounding because the phrase I
grew up with wasn't I am a man it was I
am the man and I was amazed of how I
went from this collective statement
during segregation to the seemingly
selfish statement after integration and
I wanted to ponder that so I decided to
remix that text in as many ways as I
could think of and I like to think of a
top line as a American hit timeline of
American history and the last line as a
poem and it says I'm the man who's the
man you the man what a man I am man
I am many I am am I I am I am I am
Amen yeah so fascinating but what we
learn from this experience is the most
powerful two words in the English
languages I am and we each have the
capacity to love thank you
[Applause]
[Music]